we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 30 40 750
I have time for one more call it has
been quite a day here quite a day we'll
take a call from the 210 area code
collar and 210 what's your name and
where you calling from is that San
Antonio yeah San Antonio amla I'm John
cool what's on your mind yeah I have a
question what do you think about a
progressive or libertarian alliance and
what could we do to spark you know
intellectual debate and find the common
ground over policy substance yeah so I
think that there are definitely overlaps
between sort of a traditional
libertarians and progressives when it
comes to social issues there are
sometimes some overlaps when it comes to
issues of constitutionality and free
speech I think where there's kind of a
barrier sometimes is although at first
glance you'd think on many economic
issues there'd be a natural alliance
between libertarians and progressives on
a sort of anti-corruption point of view
the sort of extreme free-market
libertarians would be at odds we had a
lot of the economic ideas of progressive
so I think that you're right think about
whether there might be some alliance
against much of what Trump is doing and
I think there's something to that but
also fundamentally you know what a true
progressive and a true libertarian might
be pretty significantly at odds on
economic policy because you know we we
think that you know the government
should do more to step in we don't I of
course don't believe in the market
controlling everything laissez-faire
capitalism that's just not what I could
leave it right yes absolutely so i think
that there's a lot of interesting that's
an interesting idea I don't know exactly
how you make it happen politically
because libertarians very often sort of
end up voting for republicans even if
they recognize that much of what
republicans stand for isn't really
aligned with them so i think there's
something to it what do you think pat
this may be an oversimplification but if
you divide policy into three categories
you have domestic foreign and social I
mean libertarians and liberals degree on
agree on two out of three of those
rights so I wouldn't be surprised I
would
imagine libertarians are more in common
with liberals and conservatives and
ought to vote democrats I think I agree
with that they don't do it and I think
there's typically the especially because
many people go get to being libertarian
from being Republicans and then saying I
don't agree with Republicans on the
social so i think becoming a libertarian
makes sense and that may be part of why
you don't see that many libertarians
voting for democrats really good
question really appreciate the call
thank you so much crap in the question
all right now the good one okay that
does it for today we are all out of time
for calls but the show is not over it
continues thanks to everybody who called
in we'll talk to you again next week
interview coming up next